[Music]
- one action
what about - off the record where we
talk about Timmy today hi guys I'm back
thanks for having me back again back no
strings attached yet oh God
so what's up yeah what's up man you know
what I never told you guys I never said
on JK news why I stopped using
DeLaGhetto because there was a lot of
people in the comments like when and why
did Tim stop using yeah we all just
assumed because you wanted to roll
because he stopped being ghetto and he's
like I'm not ghetto anymore well that's
not it Mickey well that's what you told
me that's what you said privately
off-camera like why I get oh honey
that's not true it's about principal
video I watch the video how many people
here watch the video got me I'm as
friends okay was 11 minutes long I get
it it's like what the title explained it
pretty much nobody here did it it's true
the title was is retiring the name
Timothy DeLaGhetto so I do need to watch
it I support whatever you do you don't
want to know but they want to know maybe
they don't know about two people
comments anyway I tell your life story
if you want it from from yeah I'm just
kidding you tell your story well my real
name is Tim Lee most Eno you know I've
heard it all Tim I've got it made fun of
okay and I shortened it for the same
reason you short what's the real reason
okay it was a bunch of stuff it's a
bunch of stuff but it's because pretty
rich agents came out and then I want to
make it big some reveal other Asian
again people couldn't pronounce his last
name and back in the day when you're
doing
stand up you're doing shows and [ __ ]
didn't [ __ ] up your name they [ __ ] up
your name and credits so you change it
to a more catchy last name yeah I mean
when you when you when you want to be
like when you're in your head and you
want to be like a celebrity we were
growing up and [ __ ] I think you're
supposed to stage new days name right
right so I chose Timothy DeLaGhetto cuz
delaghetto was from an episode of The
Fresh Prince and freshman's was like my
favorite show and I feel like the
freshman's like raised me and [ __ ] you
know so there's an episode where we'll
joins a Poetry Club to meet girls and
they have him say a poem a so he makes
up a poem by a poet named Raphael day
like ghetto and I was like oh [ __ ] this
one got to be the but that what's his
name but lived name no it's not no
Jeffery dressed up yeah so I had to be
like as my youtube name but I never like
in the future I never like intended for
me to like be accepting Awards as
Timothy DeLaGhetto you know in my head I
was always like whenever I get like a
big TV show or movie show I would do the
Tim delaghetto chantarangsu and
eventually just kind of phased it out
like see putting delaghetto in cause
this hilarious sale again oh wait what
happened to traffic cuz you had another
name yeah it was my rap name I can
relate I have so many nicknames I can't
keep track of them I said yeah I know
you don't like man miracle man all kind
of [ __ ] you call me ace H what's your dj
name DJ winger will you do it you do
have these men too right now I know the
wings oh sure thank you people love it
mm-hmm basically I just felt like I did
you know I didn't wanna talk about this
for a little minute because it was a
whole bunch of other [ __ ] no but it was
like it was the whole like moving on and
evolving but was also about like
embracing my Thai culture and embracing
who I am cuz like I've always tried to
push out like hey you know agent people
be proud of what you come from be proud
of like don't let them make fun of your
language in your last name did you cry
in the video um I tried to force one but
not by yourself what's your technique to
forcing the cry oh I just start making a
scrunchy face no no when I try to force
a cry I try to like yawn but with my
butt but hold my face together and then
that's good it's kind of working for me
a little bit yeah yeah and then you kind
of been it kind of hits you like a yawn
what do you mean like that you really
can you can kind of like like when you
do this but you do it like it sold it
you sold it to it okay or just don't
blink for a long time and then you can
get the tears going on but do you have
to do for a while okay whoo let's see
how long we can go without blinking
everybody go okay once I suck at this
what one two three go well I started
earlier oh yeah I'm going oh but I got
all with your ear and don't look at me
wait who still in who still in not mean
this is dumb okay I'm gone you're dumb
Hey Kiwi wouldn't do it or nothing yeah
we just started doing yeah we don't look
like hi I don't know if I blinked or not
you've been bleeding Bart your clothes
though you're the closer to crime look
at you Bart for a little [ __ ] boy look
at the bees about to cry Bart is the
most competitive like everyone dropped
out oh god what did I blink it is that
what you do you like a five-minute pause
and just help your eyes open those tears
going now it's time for me to do it why
I'm not yeah Katherine see yes you
should have done at least for the
thumbnail like it did a little like yeah
yeah yeah a lot of people do like that
yeah guys don't you if I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna cry
and then they they're like alright I'm
not good okay come back I've literally
seen people be like alright hold on real
quick for the thumbnail all right now to
talk about you see yes oh yeah that's
that's what when they call it out yeah
yeah but it's like an easy way to like
do that you like the clicks yeah mm-hmm
damn it's so misleading these days I
remember back in the day when you just
do the the whatever a video you're gonna
do right and then you find a screencap
of what you think best summarizes the
video yeah and then I guess that's not
good enough anymore but it's not even
just actors that do screen like stage
Dame's like authors do I was reading I'm
reading 1984 right now by George Orwell
and I found out that his name's on door
door well what does name his name is
something like basic white dudes by
George Redenbacher no it's not even
George it's like it's like Michael and I
look at all Whoopi Goldberg's real name
is Karen Goldberg oh my god suits a
weekend you could just be on the show
and if you disagree with are you like
whatever Karen oh my god did you read my
wikipedia my Whoopie Peter I remember
one elementary school I found out Magic
Johnson it wasn't magic and I was like
what I think it's I'm like sorry if
you're even out there did you know he's
a billionaire
is he a billionaire they're gonna come
off with a documentary on him to - a
billionaire what yeah he's alive is he
the one with the george orwell's name is
Erik Arthur Blair yeah
George Orwell it sounds scary because
they made it scary because the book well
1984 is like us right now yeah it's
pretty wild and when you say Orwellian
everyone's always like gives you chills
like dystopian Oh what's Orwellian
that's too smart for me okay oh no it's
it's like
dystopian society like the future where
we burn the pass and there's thought
police and there not a lot of things
certain things look again
it's kind of right now because then you
get cancel or say certain things oh it's
gonna get interesting too because we all
invite microphones into our homes yeah
yeah well we already have why now with
Alexa and what you know serious [ __ ]
your phone yeah he listens I swear like
when I I was Lily looking at a Parma I
told my friend I was like hey that's a
dope apartment we should check it out I
get a call from that building like an
hour later yeah and I didn't look them
up on like Zillow or anything why
building yeah that's same building as
Ohio do you guys have like Alexa in your
house and [ __ ] I have all of them I'm
plug mom and it freaks me out how's it
going I like to go into random houses
and yell for Alexa to do [ __ ] I do that
in my YouTube videos these go like hey
Google and they're like you made my [ __ ]
go up oh yeah Siri Alexa delete
everything
oh god my phone just came I canceled
everything go go play Barton geo YouTube
videos you know it's tight so my tactic
here is to say that and so he learns to
so now if he wants like listen to music
you play good god good thought dolphin
that's his favorite song I thought of
that crystal dolphin okay look the
dolphin seemed like it could be a Jo
impression to build the accent for
people yeah choose oh that's rough yeah
I know somebody who said it doesn't work
Oh TIFF said that because like oh yeah
something I ran by white people right so
she gets she says her her voice doesn't
doesn't work with Syrian [ __ ] wait what
yeah yeah no she said on some JK when
she was like yeah no like the on the
talked to text never was oh yeah that's
just that's not even racist and then
it's just just a lot yeah yeah it sucks
Perot for everyone I think but I hope
that Apple updates it to further [ __ ]
with TIFF just if it's a only test voice
that would be fine and then maybe a
mumble it's just in general like it just
won't work yeah he's gonna enunciate
yeah I love using that [ __ ] you have to
over an NC
I do appreciate the effort they try to
transcribe my voicemails because my mom
will be love it's just straight up in
Chinese and then don't like Apple Valley
undersea water really trying to like
transcribe what my mom saying and I'm
like damn that's crazy instead of just
saying it's in another language yeah you
know it's crazy my dad the other day
like he typed with an accent like
accident
okay so he was trying to say he liked
the way Joel speaks like mother well
yeah well he was trying to say mom is
giving me the silent treatment
yeah and he says mom just giving me the
siren treatment I was like how'd that
work I know he knows the real word yeah
like you reads bug yeah but I'm like
that's really what you're saying mom's
good yeah maybe
who knows they're getting freaky over
there yeah was it a kid's mom the one
that likes to dam so cans mom actually
writes in accents my grandma tried to do
that on Scrabble she was like she put
down the word pipe and you know PI P and
B have pretty they're like they're worth
three points each so yeah she's trying
to argue pi and then we're like what's
pi and she's like nope I'm one two three
four five
that's adorable yeah she was seriously
arguing it and she wasn't any funny she
was trying to be funny but also she was
trying to get away with it cuz she knows
what to get away with well people get
away with anything you know it was so
much [ __ ] do whatever you lose on triple
word score to my wife when I was 10
years old I beat my older cousin who was
like 20-something in college and her
boyfriend were 20-something at Scrabble
and I thought I was and then I beat her
ass cuz I'm trying to cheat at Scrabble
I need them as Scrabble and I was really
proud of myself
oh good job I live ever finish the game
of Scrabble or Monopoly we didn't own
that [ __ ] cuz that's just we just didn't
play educational games like that
technology when I grew up so a little
bit your baby will you play late digital
monopoly yeah basically nobody like
Nintendo 64 and [ __ ] yeah hell yeah we
had that too but he also plays Scrabble
yeah like 20 when it came up what I was
in fourth third grateful [ __ ] are you
talking about how old you could be all I
was like ten years old when antennas
working on it was like nine I didn't get
my first game console until um Sega
Saturn was my first one hmm oh it didn't
last very long
Oh Sega Saturn was was Sega's competitor
with Playstation yeah yeah did you even
get to point into the 64 were you
playing with that unplug controller
because you're [ __ ] anyway you kids
call the vintage and stuff you're like
oh that's what was coming out that's why
are you talking [ __ ] we had Nintendo Lee
was regular Nintendo yeah but the one
that had like this is small square
doesn't matter we still I heard that too
before that it was a target and they all
came out like really close to each other
so like the original Tendo I had a s 106
Super Nintendo came out when I was like
7 or 8 and then Nintendo 64 came out
when I was nine it was like all right it
was like one right after the other
stop copying us yeah stop copying us I'm
helping you guys yeah yeah that's us
Fred we invented phones yeah
Durr yeah yeah you baby we used to have
two tracks like big wigs like doing a
bunch of numbers in a row baby man I did
that too
i doesn't have anyone to text your name
for the rest of this day is stupid baby
man super big event you do you are watch
that viral video it was on e bombs world
because that's what we had before
YouTube x-cubed baby
who used to stoop a little baby man I
think when I was like first getting
online we have like YouTube actually
there what year was that
2005 yeah that's what it first column
line they're actually starting to use it
like it went from porn to YouTube that's
all we did in early YouTube you can find
porn here and there because there was
just people uploading anything yeah yeah
I'm saying so you would find like random
shades like kitten videos and then like
porn is it still that way with the
Instagram hashtags because I remember
that's like if you found a little
hashtag you'd be like a whole section of
porn on its screen yeah you can like if
you upload something like I guess I
could do like facial recognition well
before you can choose thumbnails to on
YouTube people would insert a nude
picture like right at the point where
they knew they would take the thumbnail
in the video yeah that was a thing back
then you had a time when you put the
thumbnails will just pop up and then
directly in the middle of the video yeah
I miss getting Rick Rolled role you guys
an email the one that just came up once
Akashi I would never admit to getting
rickroll never gonna let you down
there's a stupid little baby he won't
get the joke I'm rolling in butter silly
baby man
I like the oldest to follow Lee dude i
rick roll to chick by burning her CD and
that was the first song that's time and
then you broke up with her do you know
what burning a CD means yeah you know
that means baby even know mr. burns CD
he didn't light it on fire yeah burn CD
yeah
it's uh it's like when you get the the
PS for sure yeah what is that
no no no wait we'll refer to hit you
know we don't want to be as far as we
know we're up there what what does it
stand for PlayStation 4
laughs Asia one time I am I made a mix
of have I told this to perform a mix of
sexy songs from for Rick one time boy
pointing at me no no this is me holding
the CD I was doing this these are your
CD it's in that was for him hook up and
then in the middle of it you put a funny
song yes as an eternal theme song yeah
so he's all he's all like getting it in
and then it's like I think they were act
they were like cuddling it was the post
post smash and the turtle song came did
you ever play new turtles video games no
you're seeing the original cartoon do a
little baby man
we had he man how old do you think we
are not maybe they had reruns puts it
all on the same era like in 64 and
he-man by Charlie Chaplin I've seen
those videos I feel I Love Lucy guys
Lucy is [ __ ] the best that's really
good holds up 100%
yeah I watched it because we only had
like 13 channels like with the cable
that just everyone got for free
alright right right and I was like one
of the things that came on that I'm like
George Lopez I have 4 a.m. George Lopez
like his the the show on TNT is a show
you know that's them on the gentleman's
I forgot about that everything on UPN
just reminds me of being very bored in
the afternoon you p.m. really there's
EPN back in the day and no no you
remember UPN I used to watch a lot of
you know and Channel five those were
like any Levin because I had the
symptoms PLA KTLA TBS I might as well be
a local now I've been here for so long
they were growing up as a kid like in
the 70s I was born in Indiana Indiana
Indiana Indiana Indiana going on in Kona
oh yeah yeah II got I'm pretty good with
that unplug control a bit but I'm gonna
be saying to get that baby playing with
the rap cuz you were born on what 89 be
a problem he was born in the 90s man
girl g-man thought what do you like born
2005 so even one night 95 dude people
born in 2002 or 18 2002 oh [ __ ] don't
get written that kind of math she had a
Nintendo 64 when when we all had Xbox
world we all moved on ya know I donated
our n64 to you yeah yeah I still won't
right now let me to actually we have two
of them what are you talking about well
no I still want you to play it I haven't
thought you say you still Wally I
remember when there was the next one I
remember when the games II got announced
and we all thought was variant called a
Nintendo 128 oh I remember two and
they're like all the next ones coming
out in 128 what are the 64 even stand
for 64 bits yeah would the next one be
120 I get the judge now I think was even
better than that it's your turn
you know you're passing it to you what
wait what did ok afternoon 64 what do
they put out it was the we owe the game
games now we then we oh yeah GameCube
and then we wait no we came away later
it was GameCube Nintendo what what came
out we just came out I feel like no it
went we and then me you you're probably
thinking we you cuz you're still a
little big man you got confused and
that's what I had to come out with
switch cuz people about to confuse do
the little baby people you're not you're
not counting the little portable ones
are you say oh the little DS's no that's
like the gameboy upgrade that's a no
different category
did you a gameboy is even at do you know
what that is what's the game you know I
gave what color I'm considered a gameboy
I was playing yeah do you even know what
a Moltres is do that's a cookie
do you were like the realest circle okay
I was born by then have you ever heard
of a rapper - no that's pokeyman
pokeyman yeah I'm [ __ ] owning your
ass - yes bro yes okay what is it
it's pokemons no it's not as a Zelda
enemy what's that from don't Google it
by the way don't google it
don't Google that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]